what uh what do you think went wrong
for you guys like what do you think like
enjoyed cash yeah
bro what do you mean
who had a better time than enzo and cass
bro don't hate on me for living my life
people want to also what happened to me
what went wrong [ __ ] uh you
know some [ __ ] lying [ __ ] out in
phoenix but outside i remember that and
i'm from phoenix i ate yo man
i love arizona sedona's hot i love it
over there but i love arizona i totally
forgot about that it was the show
hey man big uh and you were like you
were popping up in my homies clubs and
[ __ ] at that time you were going to like
out here out here bro when i was in the
wwe and i had the cruiserweight title
and i was living in l.a you'd see me
with the title in the night club with
the yeah
i was gonna say you were very active in
la for
for a while the whole time i was in the
wwe on tv yeah you were like that's what
i mean i live with my best friends from
high school in a house in the hills like
entourage with an infinity pool and a
[ __ ] bulldog that passed away god
bless frankie man [ __ ] love you buddy
but i owe him a lot he's loyal i just
remember following you being like yo
this guy's
this guy's [ __ ] outside outside
outside so i lived it right and um man
if you're outside you're gonna have a
target on your back you know look you
know
that's what happens i'm sorry and i just
had to look at my situation and say like
dog i don't owe anybody an apology i'm
not apologizing
i lived your dream [ __ ] are you
[ __ ] kidding of course i lived your
you wish that you could fight for a
title in madison square garden win a
title in the wwe get fired with the
title around your waist and get to put
your friends on in a house in the hill
and go [ __ ] put your little brother
my brother's the biggest music video
maker out there right now he's working
with cole bennett he's his dp [ __ ] my
brother's shot who's your man post
malone's motley crew
shout out my brother he's killing it man
he's out there he's and he's up there
with the who is with the greats right
now might know him uh ba cinema okay uh
brett arndt okay my little brother the
hitman i would always see with the uh
what was that kids named tyler who had
the clothing line
you would see him because he came to all
the wrestling shows okay i mean that kid
is a super fan who gets in the front row
of all these shows and he owns a
clothing line and that was awesome to
have a friend that had these clothes
though at that time because bro
everybody thinks like you know i'm
spending all my money on gucci and [ __ ]
like
at that time i was getting a lot of
outfits on tv from homie wow like just
lacing me in the spiff like yo spiff let
me borrow like you know i would walk out
to the ring with 100k on my neck because
it was spiffs and i had friends in the
in the game in the industry and i was
just
you know using those exploits to play a
character i wasn't actually that
[ __ ] i'm not that stupid i mean
you know i [ __ ] you know i might say
i got some red bottom side but
you know i'm not that and i'm [ __ ]
blowing all my load on on
[ __ ] clothes but hey the way i saw it
was man no i had the flyest ring gear
right i invested a lot in my ring gear
but those were investments and i you
know by buying sneakers and wearing a
new pair every single week eventually
champ sports dms me we start up that wwe
relationship that's still there today i
start i literally got my own jordan
michael jordan made me jayce that's so
crazy it's crazy i have two pairs i've
only wore one
which is nuts but reggie gave them to me
michael's right-hand man i met marcus
backstage his son who's in orlando
trophy got the trophy room yeah so like
i got to know all these people through
pro wrestling and i was able to
launch a new opportunity for myself into
music which now is is you know happening